The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Hey.
Let's start.
So a few weeks ago we started
with writing a partition
function for a
statistical field that
was going to capture behavior of
a variety of systems undergoing
critical phase transitions.
And this was obtained by
integrating over configurations
of this statistical field
a rate that we wrote
on the basis of a
form of locality.
And terms that were
consistent with that
were of the form m
squared, m to the fourth.
Let's say m to the sixth.
Various types of
gradient types of terms.
And in principle, allowing for
a symmetry-breaking field that
was more in the form of h dot 1.
And again, we always
emphasized that in writing
these statistical fields,
we have to do averaging.
We have to get rid of a lot of
short wavelength fluctuations.
And essentially, the future
m of x, although I write it
as a continuum, has an
implicit short scale
below which it
does not fluctuate.
OK, so we tried to evaluate
this by certain point,
and we didn't succeed.
So we went phenomenologically
and tried to describe things
on the basis of scaling theory.
Ultimately, this
renormalization group
procedure that we would like to
apply to something like this.
Now, there is a
part of this that
is actually pretty
easy to solve.
And that's when
we ignore anything
that is higher than
second order in m.
Because once we ignore
them, we have essentially
a generalized Gaussian integral.
We can do Gaussian integrals.
So what we are going to
do is, in this lecture,
focusing on understanding
a lot about the behavior
of the Gaussian
version of the theory.
Which is certainly a
diminished version,
because it doesn't have
lots of essential things.
And then gradually putting
back all of those things
that we have not considered
at the Gaussian level.
In particular, we'll
try to do with them
with a version of a
perturbation theory.
We'll see that standard
perturbation theory has
some limitations that
we will eventually
resolve by using this
renormalization procedure.
OK.
So what happens if I do that?
Why do I say that that
theory is now solve-able?
And the key to
that is, of course,
to go into Fourier
representation.
Which, because the
theory that I wrote down
has this inherent
translational of symmetry,
Fourier representation
decouples the various m's
that are currently connected
to their neighborhood
by these gradients
and high orders.
So let's introduce
a m of q, which
is the Fourier
transform of m of x.
Let's see. m of x.
And these are all vectors.
And I should really use a
different symbol, such as m
[INAUDIBLE], to
indicate the Fourier
components of this field m of x.
But since in the context
of renormalization group
we had defined a coarse grained
field that was in tilde,
I don't want to do that.
I hope that the
argument of the function
is sufficient indicator of
whether we are in real space
or in momentum space.
Initially, I'll try
to put a tail on the m
to indicate that I'm
doing Fourier space,
but I suspect that very soon
I'll forget about the tail.
So keep that in mind.
So if I-- oops.
OK.
m of q.
So if I go back and
write what this m of x
is, it is an integral over 2,
2 pi to the, d to the minus iq
dot x with m of q.
Now, I also want
to at some stage,
since it would be cleaner
to have this rate in terms
of a product of q's, remind you
that this could have obtained,
if I hadn't gone to
the continuum version--
if I had a finite
system-- to a sum over q.
And the sum over q
would be basically
things that are separated
q values by multiples of 1
over the size of the system.
And e to the minus iq dot x.
This m with the cues
that are now discretized.
But let's remember that
the density of state
has a factor of 1 over v.
So if I use this definition,
I really should put
the 1 over v here when
I go to the discrete version.
And I emphasize this
because previously, we
had done Fourier
decomposition where
I had used the square root
of v as a normalization.
It really doesn't matter
which normalization
you use at the end as long
as you are consistent.
We'll see the advantages of
this normalization shortly.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any particular reason
for using the different
sign in the exponential?
PROFESSOR: Actually, no.
I'm not sure even whether I
used iqx here or minus iqx here.
It's just a matter
of which one you
want to stick with consistently.
At the end of the day, the phase
will not be that important.
So even if we mistake
one form or the other,
it doesn't make any difference.
So if I do that, then again,
to sort of be more precise,
I have to think about
what to do with gradients.
Gradients, I can imagine, are
the limit of something like n
at x plus A minus n
at x divided by A.
If this is a gradient
in the x direction.
And I have to take the
limit as A goes to 0.
So when I'm thinking about this
kind of functional integral,
keeping in mind that I have
a shortest landscape, maybe
one way to do it is to
imagine that I discretize
my system over here
into spacing of size A.
And then I have a
variable on each size,
and then I integrate
every place,
subject this replacement
for the gradient.
Again, what you do precisely
does not matter here.
If you remember in
the first lecture
when we were thinking
about the dl lattice system
and then using these kinds
of coupling between springs
that they're connecting nearest
neighbors, what ended up
by using this was that
when I Fourier transformed,
I had things like cosine.
And then when I expanded the
cosine close to q, close to 0,
I generated a series
that had q squared,
q to the fourth, et cetera.
So essentially, any
discretized version corresponds
to an expansion like this with
sufficient [INAUDIBLE] powers
of q in both.
So at the end of the day, when
you go through this process,
you find that you can write
the partition function after
the change of variables to m
of x to m of q to doing a whole
bunch of integrals
over different q's.
So, essentially you would
have-- actually, maybe I
will explicitly put the
product over q outside
to emphasize that essentially,
for each q I would
have to do
independent integrals.
Of course, for
each q mode I have,
since I've gone to this
representation of a vector that
is n-dimensional, I have to do
n integrals on n tilde of q.
On-- m will be the tail of q.
And if I had chosen
the square root
of V type of
normalization, the Jacobian
of the transformation from
here to here would have been 1.
Because it's kind of a
symmetric way of writing things.
Because I chose this
way of doing things,
I will have a factor of V to
the n over 2 in the denominator
here.
But again, it's
just being pedantic,
because at the
end of the day, we
don't care about these factors.
We are interested in
things like this singular
part of the partition
function as it
depends on these coordinates.
This really just gives
you an overall constant.
Of course, how many of
these constants you have
would depend basically how you
have discretized the problem.
But it is a constant independent
of tnh, not something
that we have to worry about.
Now what happens to
these Gaussian factors?
Essentially, I have put
the product over q outside.
So when I transform this
integral over xm squared
goes over to an
integral over q, m of q
squared, which then I
can write as a product
over those contributions.
And what you will get
is t plus, from here,
you will get a Kq
squared, put in Lq
to the fourth and all
kinds of order terms
that I have included.
Multiplying this m component
vector m of q squared.
Again, reminding you
this means m of q,
m of minus q, which is the
same thing as m star of q,
if you go through these
procedures over here.
There is 2.
And this factor
of the v actually
will come up over here.
So previously, I had used the
normalization square root of V,
and I didn't have this
factor of 1 over V.
Now I have put if there,
I will have that factor.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: m minus q is star q
only if it is the real field,
right?
If m is real.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
And we are dealing with
the field m of q of this.
AUDIENCE: And in the
case of superfluidity?
PROFESSOR: In the
So let's see.
So we would have a psi of q
integral d dx into the i q dot
x psi of x.
If I Fourier
transform this, I will
get a psi star of q
integral into the x
into the minus [INAUDIBLE]
x psi star of x.
So what you are saying is that
in the case where psi of x
is a complex number-- I
have psi1 plus ipsi2-- here
I would have psi1 minus ipsi2.
So here I would have
to make it a statement
that the real part
and the imaginary part
come when you Fourier transform
with an additional minus.
But let's remember
that something
like this that we
are interested is
psi1 squared plus psi2 squared.
So ultimately that minus sign
did not make any difference.
But it's good to sort of
think of all of these issues.
And in particular, we are
used to thinking of Gaussians,
where I would have a scalar and
then I would have x squared.
When I have this complex
number and I have psi of q,
psi of minus q, then
I have a real part
squared plus an
imaginary part squared.
And you have to think
about whether or not
you have changed the number
of degrees of freedom.
If you basically integrate over
all q's, you may have problems.
You may have at some point to
think about seeing psi of q
and psi of minus q star
are the same thing.
Maybe you have to integrate
over just the positive values.
But then at each q you will
have two different variables,
which is the real part
and the imaginary part.
So you have to think about all
of those doublings and halvings
that are involved
in this statement.
And in the notes,
I have the writeup
about that that you
go and precisely check
where the factors of
one half and two go.
But ultimately, it
looks as if you're
dealing with a simple
scalar quantity.
So I did not give you
that detail explicitly,
but you can go and check
it in the important issue.
The other term that we have.
One advantage of
this normalization
is that h multiplies
the integral of m
of x, which is clearly this m
with a tail for q equals to 0.
So that's [INAUDIBLE] mh
dotted by this m [INAUDIBLE].
Yes?
AUDIENCE: This is
assuming a uniform field?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's right.
So we are thinking about
the physics problem,
but we added the uniform field.
So if you are for
some physical reason
interested in a
position where you
feel you can modify that,
then this would be h of q,
m of minus q.
Actually, one reason ultimately
to choose this normalization is
that clearly what appears
here is a sum of q.
If I go over to my integral over
q, then the factor of 1 over V
disappears.
So that's one reason-- since
mostly after this, going
through the details we'll be
dealing with the continuum
version-- I prefer
this normalization.
And we can now do the
Gaussian integrals.
Basically, there's an
overall factor of 1
over V to the n over
2 for each q mode.
Then each one of these
Gaussian integrals
will leave me a factor of
root 2 pi times the variant.
So I will get 2 pi.
The variance is V
divided by t plus k
q squared plus lq to the
fourth, and so forth.
Square root, but there
are n components,
so I will get
something like this.
And then the term that
corresponds to q equals to 0
does not have any of this part.
So it will give a
contribution even
for q equals to 0
that is like this.
But you have a term that shifts
the center of integration
from m equals to 0 because
of the presence of the field.
So you will get a term that is
exponential of essentially--
completing the square-- will
give you V divided by 2t times
h squared.
Now, clearly the thing
that I'm interested
is log of Z as a
function of t and h.
I'm interested in
t and h dependents.
So there is a bunch
of things that
are constants that
I don't really care.
And then there is a, from
here, minus 1/2, actually
minus n 1/2 sum over q log of t
plus k q squared and so forth.
And plus here, I have
V a squared over 2t.
So I can define
something that's like
if the energy from log of
Z divided by the volume.
And you can see
that once I replace
this sum of a q
with an integral,
I will get a factor of volume
that I can disregard then.
So there's some other constant.
And then I have plus n over 2
integral over q divided by q pi
to the d log of q plus k
q squared, and so forth.
Minus V k squared divided by 2t.
Now, again, the
question is what's
the range of q's that
I have to integrate,
given that I'm making things
that are coarse grained.
Now, if I were to really
discretize my system
and, say, put it on
q and you plot this,
then the allowed values
of q would leave on
the [INAUDIBLE] zone.
[INAUDIBLE] zone, say, in
the different directions in q
would be something
like the q that
would be centered
around pi over a.
But it would be centered
at 0, but then you
would have pi plus pi over a.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The d would
disappear, right?
PROFESSOR: The d would disappear
because I divided by it.
So in principle, if I had
done the discretization
to a cube and plot this, I would
have been integrating over q
that this would find
to a cube like this.
But maybe I chose
some other lattice
like a diamond
lattice, et cetera.
Then the shape of this
thing would change.
But what's the meaning of doing
the whole thing on a lattice
anyway?
The thing that I want
to do is to make sure
that I have done some
averaging in order to remove
short wavelength fluctuations.
So a much more natural way to
do that averaging and removing
short wavelength
operations is to say
that my field has only
Fourier components that
are from 0 to some maximum
value of lambda, which
is the inverse of some radiant.
And if you are worried about
the difference in integration
between doing things on
this nice mirror that
has nice symmetry and
maybe doing it on a cube,
then the difference
is essentially
the bit of integration that
you would have to do over here.
But the function that
you are integrating
his no singularities
for large values of q.
You are interested
in the singularities
of the function
when t goes to 0.
And then the log
has singularities
when its argument goes to 0.
So I should be interested,
as far as singularities
are concerned, only in the
vicinity of this point anyway.
What I do out there,
whether I replace the sphere
with the cube or
et cetera, will add
some other non-singular
term over here,
which I don't really care.
Actually, if I do that,
this non-singular term
here could be actually
functions of t.
But they would be very perfect
and regular functions of t.
Like constant plus
alpha t, plus pheta q
squared, et cetera, that
have no singularities.
So if I'm interested
in singularities,
I am going to be
focused on that.
Now actually, we
encountered this integral
before when we were
looking at corrections
to the saddle-point
approximation.
And if you remember what
we did then was to take,
let's say, C of d
of h across 0 while
taking two derivatives of this
free energy with respect to t.
And then we ended
up with an integral.
There's a minus
sign here over d.
n over 2 integral
dt 2 pi squared.
2 pi to the d.
Taking two derivatives
of the log.
The first derivative will
give me 1 over the argument.
The second derivative will give
me 1 over the argument squared.
One side take care
of the minus sign.
Now, I think this is
a kind of integral,
after I have focused
on the singular part,
that I can replace when
integrating over a sphere.
Now, when I integrate
over a sphere,
I may be concerned about what's
going on at small values.
At q, at small values of
q, as long as t is around,
I have no problem.
When t goes to 0, I
will have to worry
about the singularity
that comes from 1 over k,
2 squared, et cetera.
So that's really the singularity
that I'm interested in.
Exactly what happens
at large q, I'm
not really all
that interested in.
And in particular, what I can
do is I can rescale things.
I can call q squared
over t to the x squared.
So I can essentially make
that change over there.
So that whenever I
see a factor of q,
I replace it with t
over k to the 1/2 x.
What happens here?
I have, first of all, n over 2.
I have 1 over 2 pi to the d.
Writing this in terms
of spherical symmetry,
I will have the solid
angle d dimensions.
And then I would have
q to d minus 1 q.
Every time I put a factor of
q, I can replace it with this.
So I would have a t over
k with a power of q/2.
And then I have my integral
that becomes the x,
x to the d minus 1, 1 plus
x squared plus potentially
higher order things like this.
Now, the upper cut-off
for x is in fact
square root k over
t times lambda.
And we are interested in the
limit of when t goes to 0.
So that upper limit is
essentially going to infinity.
Now, whether or
not this integral,
if I learn to ignore
higher order terms
and focus on the first
term, exists really
depends on whether d is larger,
d minus 1 plus 1 d minus 4
is positive or negative.
And in particular,
if I learn to get rid
of all those higher order terms.
And basically, the
argument for that
is the things that would go
with x to the fourth, et cetera,
if we carry additional
factors of t--
and hopefully getting rid
of them as to go to 0--
will give me an
integral like this.
This will exist only
if I am in dimensions
d that is less than 4.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you
missing the factors of t
over t that comes
with the denominator?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
There is a factor
of 1 over t here.
So I have to put
out the factor of t.
Write this as 1 plus k
over t plus the element
of t, et cetera.
So there is a
factor of 1 over t.
AUDIENCE: t squared.
PROFESSOR: And
that's a factor of t
squared, because
that's two powers.
So if I'm in dimensions d
less than 4, what I can write
is that this c singular,
this as t goes to 0.
The leading behavior,
this goes to the constant.
So as we discussed, after all
of the mistakes that I made,
there will be some overall
coefficient A. The power of t
will be d over 2 minus 2.
d over 2 came from
the integrations.
1 over t squared came
from the denominator.
And then if I were to expand
all of these other terms
that we've ignored,
higher powers of-- here
I will get various series
that will correct this.
But the leading key dependents
in dimensions less than 4
is this thing that we
had seen previously.
Now I can take this, and
you see that in dimensions
d less than 4,
this is a singular
term that is diversion.
If I were to say
what kind of thing
was of the energy that
gave result to this?
Then it would say that
if the energy must
have had some other constant
that was proportionate of the t
to the d over 2, that when
I put two derivatives,
I got something like this.
Of course, if the
energy could also
have had a term that was linear
in t, I wouldn't have seen it.
So there is a singular part.
Essentially, if I were to do
that integral in dimensions
less than fourth, I will
get a leading singularity
that is applied.
I will get a singularity
that is like this.
I will get additional terms
per constant-- t, t squared,
et cetera-- and
singular terms that
are subbing in to this one.
And then, of course,
I have a term
that is minus h squared over t
if I were to include this here.
So why don't I write the answer
as B minus h divided by t
to the 1/2 plus d/4,
the whole thing squared.
So what I did was essentially
I divided and multiplied
by inputting d and put the whole
thing in the form of h divided
by t to something squared?
Why did I do that?
It's because we had first
related a singular form
for the energies in the scaling
picture that had the E to the 2
minus alpha in front of
them and the function of h t
to the delta.
And all I wanted to emphasize
is that this picture, 2 minus
alpha is d over 2.
And the thing that we
call the gap exponent
is 1/2 plus d over 4.
Of course, I can't
use this theory
as a description of the case.
And the reason for that is
that the Gaussian theory
exists and is well-defined
only as long as t is positive.
Because once t becomes
negative, then the rate
essentially becomes ill-defined.
Because if I look at the
various rates that I have here,
we certainly-- the
rate for q equals to 0.
It is proportional
to minus t over 2v.
If the t changes sign, rather
than having a Gaussian,
I have essentially a rate that
is maximized as [INAUDIBLE].
So clearly, again, by
issue of stability,
the theory for t negative does
not describe a stable theory.
And that's why n to the
fourth and all of those terms
will be necessary to describe
that side of the phase
transition.
So if you like, this is
a kind of a description
of a singularity that exists
only in this half of the space.
Kind of reminiscent of coming
from the disordered side,
but I don't want to give
it more reality than that.
It's a mathematical construct.
If we want to venture
to make the connection
to the actual phase
transition, we
have to prove the
n to the fourth.
Now, the only reason to go
and recap this Gaussian theory
is because since
it is solve-able,
we can try to use
it as a toy model
to apply the various steps
of renormalization group
that we had outlined
last lecture.
And once we understand the
steps of renormalization group
for this theory, then it
gives us an anchoring point
when we describe
the full theory that
has n to the fourth,
et cetera-- how
to sort of start with the
renormalization approach
to the theory as we understand
and do the more complicated.
So essentially, as I said, it's
not really a phase transition
that can be described
by this theory.
It's a singularity.
But its value is that it is
this fully-modelled anchoring
point for the full theory
that we are describing.
So what we want to do is to do
an RG for the Gaussian model.
So what is the procedure.
We have a theory best
described in the space
of variables q, the
Fourier variables.
Where I have modes that
exist between 0-- very long
wavelength-- to lambda, which
is the inverse of some shortest
wavelength that I'm allowing.
And so basically, I have
a bunch of modes m of q
that are defined in
this range of qx.
The first step of RG
was to coarse grain.
The idea of coarse graining was
to change the scale over which
you were doing the
averaging from some a to ba.
So average from a to
ba of fluctuations.
So once I do that,
at the end of the day
I have fluctuations whose
minimum wavelength has
gone from a to ba.
So that means that q max, after
I go and do this procedure,
is the previous q max that I
had divided by a factor of b.
So basically, at the end
of the day I want to have,
after coarse graining,
variables that only exist up
to lambda over b.
Whereas previously,
they existed after that.
So this is very
easy at this level.
All I can do is to
replace this m tilde of q
in terms of two sets.
I will call it to
be sigma if q is
greater than this lambda over b.
That is, everybody that
is out here, their q--
I will call it q larger.
Everybody that is here,
their q I will call q lesser.
And all the modes
that were here,
I will give them
a different name.
The ones here I will call sigma.
The ones here, if q
less than lambda over b,
will get called m tilde.
So I just renamed my variables.
So essentially, right
here I had integration
over all of the modes.
I just renamed some of
the modes that were inside
q lesser and sigma--
and tilde, the ones that
are outside q greater.
So what I have to do
for my Gaussian theory.
Let's write it rather
than in this form
that was discrete in
terms of the continuum.
I have to iterate over all
configurations of these Fourier
modes.
So I have these m tilde of q's.
And the wave that I have
to assign to them when
I look at the continuum is
exponential, integral in dq
q to pi to the d.
T plus kq squared, and so forth.
And tilde of q squared.
And then I had the one
term that was hm of 0.
What I have done is
to simply rewrite
this as two sets of
integrations over the-- whoops.
This was m.
m, let's call is sigma
first-- sigma of q
larger integrate over
m tilde of q lesser.
And actually, you can
see that the modes here
and the modes here don't
talk to each other.
And that's really the advantage
of doing the Gaussian theory.
And the thing that allowed
me to solve the problem here
and also to do the
coarse graining there.
Once we do things
like n to the fourth,
then I will have
couplings between modes
that go across between
the three sets.
And then the problem
becomes difficult.
But now that I
don't have that, I
can actually separately write
the integral as two parts.
And this is for q lesser.
And for each one of them, I
essentially have the same rate.
The integral over q
greater goes between lambda
over d and lambda.
The integral over
m tilde of q lesser
is essentially the same thing.
Exponential minus integral
0 to lambda over d. dv
q lesser to five to the d,
t plus kq lesser squared,
and so forth.
And q lesser squared.
And then I have the additional
term which sits at 0.
It is part of the modes that
are assigned with q lesser.
OK?
Fine.
Nothing particularly
profound here.
In fact, it's very simple.
It's just renaming
two sets of modes.
And the averaging
that I have to do,
and getting rid of
the fluctuations
at short wavelength,
here is very trickier.
Because this is just a
bunch of integrations
that I had to do over here,
but it is only over things
that are sitting close to
the edge of this [INAUDIBLE].
So essentially, the
integrations over these modes
is doing this
integral over here,
from lambda over d to lambda,
and none of the singularities
has anything to do with
the range of integration
from lambda over d to lambda.
So the result of
doing all of that
is simply just a constant--
but not a constant.
It's a function of t that
is completely non-singular
and have a nice state of
expansion powers of t.
A kind of [INAUDIBLE] I
call non-singular functions
sometimes.
Constant thing is
that eventually
if you take sufficiently
high derivatives,
I guess, of this value, the
t dependents [INAUDIBLE].
So all of the interesting thing
is really in this m tilde of k
lesser.
And really, the eventual
process of renormalization
in this picture is
something like this.
That all of the
singularities are
sitting at the center of this
kind of orange-shaped entity.
And rather than biting
the whole thing,
you kind of cut it slowly
and slowly from the edge,
approaching to where all
of the exciting things
are at the center.
For this problem
of the Gaussian,
it turns out to be
trivial to do so.
But for the more
general problem,
it can be interesting because
procedure is the same.
We are interested in
what's happening here,
but we gradually peel
of things that we
know don't cause anything
difficult for the problems.
So then I have to
multiply with this,
and I have found in some sense
a probability for configurations
of the coarse grain system,
which is simply given by this.
But then renormalization
group has two other steps.
The second step was to
say, well, in real space,
as we said, the picture
that is represented
by these coarse grain
variables is grainy.
If my pixels were previously
one by one by one,
now my pixels are d by d by d.
So I can make my picture look
to have the same resolution
as my initial
picture if I rescale
all of the events
for a factor of t.
In momentum representation,
or intuitive presentation,
it corresponds to rescaling all
of the q's by a factor of B.
And clearly, what
that serves to achieve
is that if I replace q
lesser with B times q prime,
then the maximum value will
go back to 0 to lambda.
So by doing this
one in formation,
I can ensure that the upper
cut-off is, in fact, lambda
again.
Now, there was another
thing, which in real space
we said that we defined m
prime to be m tilde rescaled
by some factor zeta.
I had to do a change
of the contrast.
I did have to do the
same change of contrast
here, except that the variables
that I am dealing with here,
it was in x coordinates.
What I want to do it
is in the q coordinate.
So I will call m with
a tail prime of q prime
to be m tilde of q
prime by a factor of z.
The difference between
the z and the zeta, which
is real space and Fourier
space is just the fact
that in going from
one to the other,
you have to do
integrations over space.
So dimensionally,
there is a factor of b
to the d difference between
the rescaling of this quantity
and that quantity,
and if you want to use
or the other zeta against
b to the minus d and z.
But since we would be doing
everything in Fourier space,
we would just use this
factor traditionally.
So if I do that, what do I find?
I find that Z of t of h is
exponential of some singular,
non-singular dependents.
And then I have to integrate
over these new variables,
m prime of q prime.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In your real
space renormalization
your m tilde is a
function of an x.
But in your Fourier
space representation
your m tilde is a
function of q prime?
PROFESSOR: I guess I could have
written here x prime, also.
It doesn't really matter.
So do you have here?
You have exponential
minus the integral.
The integration for q prime now
is going back to 0 to lambda.
I have db of q prime
divided by 2 pi to the d.
Now, you see that every time
I have a q-- V or q, q lesser,
in fact-- I have
to go to q prime
by introducing a
factor of the inverse.
So there will be a total
factor of V to the minus V
that comes from
this integration.
And that will multiply t.
That will multiply
kb to the minus d.
But then here I have to q's
because of the q squared there.
Again, doing the same thing, I
will get V to the d minus two.
I had q plus 2, if you like.
And then the next l would
be lb to the d minus 4.
And you can see that as I have
higher and higher derivatives
of q, I get higher and
higher powers with negative
[INAUDIBLE].
But then I have m tilde that I
want to replace with m prime.
And that process will give
me a factor of z squared.
And then I have m prime
of q prime squared.
There is no integration
for this terms.
It's just one mode.
But each mode I have
rescaled by a factor of z.
So I will have a term that
is z h dot m prime of 0.
So what we see is that
what we have managed to do
is to make the Gaussian
integration over
here precisely the same thing
as the Gaussian integration
that I started with.
So I can conclude
that this function tnh
that I am interested in has
a path that is non-singular.
But its singular
part is the same
as the same z calculated for
a bunch of new parameters.
And in particular, the
new t is v to the minus
d z squared the old t.
The new k is b to the minus
d minus 2 z squared q.
The new L would be to the
minus d minus 4 z squared L,
and so forth.
And the new h is zh.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There should be q
prime squared and q prime 4?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
This is my day to do a
lot of algebraic errors.
OK.
So what is the
change in parameters?
So I wrote it over there.
So this kind of captures
the very simplest type
of renormalization.
Actually, all I did
was a scaling analysis.
If I were to change
positions by a factor of b
and change the magnitude of my
field m by a factor z or zeta,
this is the kind of
results that I will get.
Now, how can we make this
capture the kind of picture
that we have over here in the
language of renormalization?
Want to be able to
change two parameters
and reach a fixed point.
So we know that kind of
[INAUDIBLE] that t and h
have to go to 0.
They are the variables
that determine essentially
whether you are at this
said similar point.
So if t and h I forget, the
next most important term that
comes into play is k prime,
which is some function of k.
And if I want to be
at the fixed point,
I may want to choose
the factor z such
that k prime is the same as k.
So choose z such
that k prime is k.
And that tells me
immediately that z
would be b to the power
of 1 plus d over 2.
If I choose that particular
form of z, then what do I get?
I get t prime is z
squared b to the minus b.
So when I do that, I
will get b squared t.
I get that h prime
is just z times h.
So it is b to the 1
plus b over 2 times h.
These are both directions that
as b becomes larger than 1,
b prime becomes larger than th
prime, becomes larger than h.
These are relevant directions.
I would associate with them
eigenvalues y dt minus 2.
Divide h.
That is 1 plus d over 2.
So if I go according to the
scaling construction that we
had before, f singular
of tnh is t to the power
d over y dt, some
scaling function of h,
g to the power of
divide h over y dt.
This is what we have
established before.
With these values I will
get t to the d over 2,
some scaling function of h, t to
the power of 1/2 plus d over 4.
We can immediately compare this
expression and this expression
that we have over here.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Wait.
What's the reason
to choose scale
as the parameter that maps
onto itself and not L?
PROFESSOR: OK.
I'll come to that.
So having gone this far,
let's see what l is doing.
So if I put here-- you
can see that clearly L
has v to the minus
2 compared to k.
So currently, the way
that we established,
L prime is b to the minus 2m.
If I had a higher
derivative, it would
be b to a minus larger
number, et cetera.
So L, out of these other things,
are irrelevant variables.
So they are essentially
under rescaling,
under looking at the system
in larger and larger scale,
they will go to 0.
And I did get a system that has
the same topological structure
as what I had established here.
Because I have to
tune two parameters
in order to reach
the critical point.
Let's say I had
chosen something else.
If I had chosen z such
that L prime equals to L.
I could do that.
Then all of the derivatives that
are higher factors of q in this
[INAUDIBLE], they would
be all irrelevant.
But then I would
have k, t, and h
all with irrelevant variables.
So yeah, it could be that
there is some physics.
I mean, certainly
mathematically I
can ask the system what
happens if k goes to 0.
I kind of ignore
the k dependencies
that I have in all
of these expressions,
but there are going to be
singular dependencies on k.
So if there is indeed
some experimental system
in which you have to tune,
in addition temperature,
something that has
to do with the way
that the spins or
degrees of freedom
are coupled to each other,
and that coupling changes sign
from being positive
to being negative,
you go from one type of behavior
to another type of behavior,
maybe this would be
a good thing for it.
But you can see the
kind of structure
you would get if k has to go
to 0, you go from a structure
where things want to be
in the same direction
to things that want
to be anti-parallel.
And then clearly you need higher
order terms to stabilize things
so that your
singularity does not
go all the way to 0
wavelength, et cetera.
So one can actually come
up with physical systems
that kind of resemble
that, were there
is some landscape
that is also chosen.
But for this very simplest
thing that we are doing,
this is what is going on.
But you could have also
asked the other question.
So clearly we
understand what happens
if you choose z so
that some term is fixed
and everything above it is
relevant, everything below it
is irrelevant.
But why not choose z
such that t is fixed?
So that's going to
be b to the d over 2,
then t prime equals to t.
If I choose that, then
clearly the coupling k
will already be irrelevant.
So this is actually a
reasonable fixed point.
It's a fixed one that
corresponds to a system
where k has gone
to 0, which means
that the different points
don't talk to each other.
Remember, when we
were discussing
the behavior of correlation
lens at fixed points,
there was two possibilities--
either the correlation
lens was infinite or it was 0.
So if I choose this, then k
prime will go eventually to 0.
I go towards a system in
which the degrees of freedom
are completely decoupled
from each other.
Perfectly well-behaved.
Fixed behavior that corresponds
to 0 correlation lens.
And you can see that if
I go through this formula
that I told you over
here, zeta in real space
would be b to the
minus d over 2.
And what that means
is that if you average
independent variables
over a size b,
the scale of fluctuation is
because of the central limit
theeorem is the square
root of the volume.
So that's how it scales.
So essentially, what's
at the end of the story?
That's a behavior in which there
is only one coefficient event--
forget about h.
The eventual rate is just t over
2m squared at different points.
That's the central limit here.
So through a different route, we
have rediscovered, if you like,
the central limit theorem.
Because if you average lots
of uncorrelated variables,
you will generate
Gaussian rates.
So what we are really
after in this language
is how to generalize the
central limit theorem, how to--
as we find the analog of
a Gaussian, the degrees
of freedom that
are not correlated
but talk to their neighborhood.
So the kind of field
theory that we are after
are these generalizations
of central limit theorem
to the types of
field theories that
have some locality enablement.
AUDIENCE: Question.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So wherever you can
define the renormalization
you're finding different z's?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: We can tune
how many parameters we
want to be able to--
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
Yes.
And that's where the
physics comes into play.
Mathematically, there's a whole
set of different fixed points
that you can construct for
choosing different z's.
You have to decide
which one of them
corresponds to the
physical problem
that you are working on.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So if the fixed point
stops being just defined
by the nature of the
system, but it's also
depends on how we
define renormalization?
On mathematical
descriptions and--
PROFESSOR: If by how we
define renormalization looking
to choose z, yes,
I agree with you.
Yes.
But again, you have
this possibility
of looking at the system
at different scales.
But we have been very agnostic
about what that system is.
And so you how many
ways of doing things.
Ultimately, you need some
reality to come and choose
among these different ways.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you
do want to keep k
a relevant variable in
group problems, right?
PROFESSOR: No.
I make k to be a fixed variable.
AUDIENCE: Oh, exactly.
Why don't you add a small
amount, like an absolute
to the power of bf and
[INAUDIBLE] point z.
Plus or minus, doesn't matter.
Why the equality
assumption exactly?
And the smaller one
doesn't change anything?
All the other variables
like L become irrelevant?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the point is that it
is b raised to some power.
So here I had, I don't
know, Katie k prime was k.
And you say, why not
kb to the absolute?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
PROFESSOR: Now,
the thing that I'm
interested in what happens
at larger and larger scale.
So in principle, I
should be able to make v
as large as I want.
So I don't have the
freedom that you mentioned.
And you are right in
the sense that, OK,
what does it mean
whether this ratio is
larger than or
smaller than what?
But the point is that
once you have selected
some parameter in your system--
L or whatever you have,
some value-- you can, by
playing around with this,
choose a value of V
for any epsilon such
that you reach that limit.
So by doing this, you in a
sense have defined a lens scale.
The lens scale would
depend on epsilon,
and you would have
different behaviors,
whether you have shorter
than that lens scale
or larger than that lens scale.
So this has to be done precisely
because of this freedom
of making b larger, and so on.
Now, if you are dealing
with a finite system
and you can't make your b
much larger than something
or whatever, then
you're perfectly right.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Physically,
z or zeta should
be whatever type quantity
is needed to actually make
it look exactly the same--
where it keeps coming out.
PROFESSOR: Exactly, yes.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: And then we
know, because we already
know that we have two
relevant variables,
that z has to look this
way for a system that
has two relevant variables.
PROFESSOR: For the
Gaussian one, right.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But then if we had a
different kind of system,
then actually, just going
from the physical perspective,
we would need a different z
to make things look the same.
And that would give
us a different number
of variables here.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's right.
Now, in terms of that
practically in all cases
we either are dealing
with a phase that
has 0 correlation
on that, and then
this Gaussian behavior
and central limit theorem
is what we are dealing-- and the
averaging is by 1 over volume.
Or we have something
that is very pretty
close to this big [INAUDIBLE]
that we have now discovered,
which is just the
gradient squared.
And that has its own
scaling according
to these powers that
I have found here,
and I will explain
that more deeply.
It turns out that at
the end of the day,
that when we look at
real phase transitions,
all of these exponents will
change, but not too much.
So this Gaussian fixed point
is actually in some sense
rather close to where
we want to end up.
So that's why it's also an
important anchoring point,
as I just mentioned.
Again, I said that
essentially what we did
was take the rate that
we had originally,
and we did a rescaling.
So basically, we
replace x by-- let
me get the directions there.
So we replace x by bx prime.
If I had started
being in real space,
I would have replaced
m with zeta m prime.
m after getting rid of
some degrees of freedom.
Again, zeta m prime.
Before I just do that to the
rate that I had written before,
there was a beta h.
Which was we could derive
d d x t over 2m squared, um
to the fourth and
higher order terms,
k over 2 gradient m squared, L
over 2 Laplacian of m squared
and so forth.
Just do this
replacement of things.
What do I get?
I get that t prime
is b to the d.
Whenever I see x, I
replace it with dx prime.
Whenever I see m, I replace
it with zeta m prime.
So I get here the zeta squared.
u prime would be b to
the d zeta to the fourth.
k prime would be b to the
b minus 2 zeta squared.
L prime would be
b to the d minus 4
zeta squared, and so forth.
Essentially.
All I did was replace x with b
times x prime and m with zeta m
prime.
If I do that
throughout, you can see
how the various
factors will change.
So I didn't do all of
these integrations,
et cetera that I did over here.
I just did the dimensional
analysis, if you like.
And within that dimensional
analysis now in real space,
if I set k prime to be k, you
can see that zeta is d to the 2
minus d over 2.
And again, you can see
that once I have fixed k,
all of the things that have the
same power of m but two higher
derivatives would get a
factor of b to the minus 2,
just as we had over here.
Again, with this
choice, you can check
that if I put it back here,
I would get b squared.
But let's imagine that I have
a generalization of m to the n.
If I have a term that
multiplies m to some power p--
with the coefficient up-- then
under this kind of rescaling
I will get up prime is b to the
d zeta to the power of p, up.
And with this choice
of zeta, what do I get?
I will get b to the d.
And then I will get plus p
1 minus d over 2 times up.
Which I can define to be b
to some power yp times up.
Look here to make sure.
So my yp, the
dimension of something
that multiplies
m to some power p
is simply p plus
d 1 minus p or 2.
And let's check some things.
I have y1.
y1 would correspond to a
magnetic field, something
that is proportional
to the m itself.
And if I push p close to 1,
I will get 1 plus d over 2.
And that is, indeed, the
yh that we had over here.
1 plus d over 2.
So this is yh.
If I ask what is
multiplying m squared,
I put p equals to 2 here.
I will get 2, and then here
I would get 1 minus 2 over 2.
So that's the same thing.
This is the thing that we
were calling before yt.
We didn't include any
nq term in the theory,
didn't make sense to us.
But we certainly
included the u that
was multiplied in
m to the fourth.
AUDIENCE: So is the p
[INAUDIBLE] in the yp?
PROFESSOR: There is p times
1 plus d 1 minus p over 2.
p over 2.
Just rewrote it.
If I look at 4, here would be 4.
And then I would put 1 minus
4 over 2, which is 1 minus 2,
which is minus 1.
So I would get 4 minus z.
If I look at y6, I
would get 6 minus 2d.
And so forth.
So if I just do
dimensional analysis
and I say that I start with a
fixed point that corresponds
to gradient of m squared,
and everybody else 0,
and I ask, if in the
vicinity of the fixed point
where k is fixed
and everybody else
is 0 I put on a little bit
up any of these other terms,
what happens?
And I find that what happens
is that certainly the h
term, the term that is
linear, will be relevant.
The term that is m
squared is relevant.
Whether or not all the
other terms in the series--
like m to the fourth, m
to the sixth, et cetera--
will be relevant
depends on dimension.
So once more we've hit
this dimensional fork.
So the term m to
the fourth that we
said is crucial to getting this
theory to have some meaning--
and there's no reason for it
to be absent-- is, in fact,
relevant.
In fact, close to
three dimensions
you would say that that's
really the only other term that
is relevant.
And you'd say, well,
it's almost good enough.
But almost good enough
is not sufficient.
If we want to describe a
physical theory that has only
two relevant directions, we
cannot use this fixed point,
because this fixed point has
three relevant directions
in three dimensions.
We have to deal
with this somehow.
So what will we do?
Next is to explicitly
include this m to the fourth.
In fact, we will include
all the other terms, also.
But we will see that all the
other terms, all the higher
powers, are irrelevant
in the same sense
that all of these
higher derivative terms
are irrelevant.
But that m to the
fourth term is something
that we really have
to take care of.
And we will do that.